[Music]
[ __ ] and break the nail i'll brush my
oh my goodness gracious welcome back to
the break room so good to see you
roomies glad you're here all you
breakers out there this is our daily
show that keeps you updated on just
what's going on on nerd news right here
from our very own break room at new
rockstars headquarters in a secret
location that we will never reveal so
you can never come find us uh we got a
big show today we got tons to discuss
about last night's kenobi show uh some
more thor news uh and of course miss
marvel also had a show so many shows so
be sure to stick around we'll get to all
of it today uh but first i gotta
introduce the wonderful people i'm
sitting with uh across the table from me
we got whitney van lane
oh my goodness uh next to her we have
jessica clement
james you're what i didn't choke today
you have a joke today oh yeah yes
yesterday she joked
not when it came to the game of
basketball
but i never choke when i come up to the
net that's right that's right she dumps
it she dunks on the 10-foot rim uh and
next to her of course we've got tommy
beckham oh i certainly didn't choke
today but i did gag a bit all right come
on it's so early in this show uh uh if
you if you want to hear more about the
disgusting things tommy absolutely why
is that disgusting well we gotta do it
early because that's how we know the
real ones will stay that's right we
gotta scare off the fans the babies we
gotta scare off
i'm the horny police and if i see any
horny people here or in the chat going
straight to jail straight to jail that's
right jessica's watching you in the chat
so you better watch out yeah uh we do
have our swear jar today we have it okay
we're not going to curse on this show
all right there are rules in place on
the internet and we're not going to
break them but it's really hard if you
send in some super chats for some of us
and those super chats add up to 100
we will break the swear jar and we will
allow you in the chat to vote who gets
to swear uh if we make it to the 200
mark maybe we'll swear again and we'll
put a little extra
spice on it beyond that i don't know can
we get there is it possible i don't know
it's a wednesday it's payday though for
a lot of people yeah maybe you got that
checked maybe you want to get through
the marvel dubliner cheddar cheese oh
yeah balloons in here dogs yeah yeah but
make sure you pay your cable bill first
you got to get keep that internet you
know what i mean you gotta keep that
internet uh when's the government gonna
give us free internet let's forget the
show oh my god i gotta give me free rent
i didn't pay to live i didn't ask to
live i didn't ask for this listen if
you're watching i didn't ask you you
were all hired by jesus christ the day
you were born the day you were born you
were hired by jesus christ
are you in god's army the kiss army i
sure am in god's army no the kiss army
are the knights in the satan services
[Music]
want to address something and it is not
christian
at all it is actually very far from it
because we got another episode of uh ms
marvel that's right on straight to the
telly last night um you turned on your
telly it was there you turned it on this
morning it was there and it was episode
two and we are going to give you guys
just a little spoiler free review no
spoilers just in case you haven't seen
it yet
um but i really liked this episode how
did you guys feel about it i mean i
really loved it i hated it
that is no it's the opposite thing i
will ever say this has become my
favorite mcu tv
it is my favorite show one division made
me forget that it was like an mcu thing
and but this really makes me forget and
sometimes you need to get pulled out of
it
yeah we we we're going to have like a
full discussion of miss marvel tomorrow
today we're really going to talk obi-wan
kenobi yeah but we just wanted to give
like a little highlights of miss marvel
and i just want to go on record i also
enjoy the show
and i want to say this particularly for
those of you that are fans of 80s movies
check out the fashion in episode 2
because there are some
homages that i found homage to mean
girls
yeah there's also that dude okay i like
it
there are a lot of like very solid pop
culture oh my gosh
so does this confirm lindsay lohan
exists in the marvel cinematic cinematic
universe but i also really liked in this
how they kind of
blended like history and mysticism when
they were talking about like their
family and all of that
stuff the partition gets in there and i
think that that's something that
marvel's been kind of doing really well
lately is blending like real life events
yeah into things that could have a yes
because i think kevin feige is still
stopping them on like major properties
doing it which is pissing me off the
movie because i don't like the movies
but i love that miss marvel's doing it
and i hope they look into that and
they're like this worked really well
with ms marvel it's like yeah because
people actually use the internet i like
let them use the internet i i gotta be
honest i did not love that captain
america winter soldier made my divorce
cannon so i felt like that was taking
real life a step too far but
you know what they can't announce your
divorce they did yes
okay so mo said in the super chat bruno
is totally dressed like marty mcfly it
took me a hot second yeah then i was
like why is he dressed up like marty
victor that's what i was that's what i
wanted to mo good job that's what i want
people to look out for a couple other
things too but uh yeah so yeah look out
for those three three fashions
yeah we three fashions yeah i'm loving
this show uh big fan my wife loves it
too
am i too old for this show i don't know
i don't care it's great it brings me a
lot of joy i feel great five years off
from the actress so i think we're all
fine well i'm an old man but i really
love the cinematography on the show it's
very cool they're making awesome shots
all the time there's a great clip uh
from the first episode when she lays
back on the couch or whatever you can
find a little thing on twitter about it
where they show the camera rig they had
to build it took them like
days to get that right but it's like
such a good shot and they're just trying
hard in a good way on this show and i
really like that with the music i love
the color i love the rotoscoping
i love all of it it's great choices are
great also if you get him if you're in
high school right now and you get
invited to a party and someone's going
to jump off the roof into the pool oh i
get it it's not safe don't do it but
don't shout out in front of me but bruno
come on be cool yeah don't shout out
also though
okay can i bring up something great that
was that kid brand new to the school the
first thing he does is dive jump off the
roof into a pool he's clearly the hot
senior because they kept mentioning all
right senior who's seen almost famous
one two minutes
i have a golden god i
but i hope you have seen it by now yeah
if you haven't seen almost famous go
watch it sorry you missed the boat on
that avril says who gives a fudge i'm 26
and i'm watching it well cool you're a
few years older than me but i wish i was
25 i wish i was 20.
adorable uh i remember that yeah
i remember that 30 years ago it was
great i in a recent press conference too
uh for the show our own eric vos yeah uh
got a sweet sweet shout out i really
liked that it was a sweet one it was
very very uh from the
start of the show aman valani i think we
have a club of it john come on because
uh this person
wrote it in a while ago so i want to
give it to eric voss from the new rocks
yeah
i hear you're a fan here you're a fan
is kamala subscribed on youtube to any
real life marvel youtube channels
and and and there's a little note you
have our permission to make us mcu canon
i watched their last video and they
totally
mentioned i i don't know if new
rockstars is canon in the mcu
i would love them to be i think a
version of them is a variant if you will
um
yeah
hi eric
i love you
that's it all right thank you she means
it she literally just sent me a video of
the of the mention yesterday two days
ago yeah like i have billboards with my
face on it but but like him saying my
name correctly and and like breaking
down our trailers was bigger than any
billboard ever like that's so true
it's
thank you for that
is she a roomie is she a breaker i think
it's a special i think it's official to
say anytime celebrities talk about new
rock stars i'm like they've possibly
seen me when serena
williams watches new rock stars you guys
tennis uh athlete olympian a beautiful
dancer watches new rock stars i broke
down to my knees i told my mom i called
my grandmother said we can come back out
the shadows that's right
quinto quinta brunson famous new
rockstars fan from abbott elementary
loves her loves our channel uh and all
of you in the chat we love
if we're not famous we really don't no
no we care we care i don't think anyone
famous likes me so you guys are you guys
are very famous people some of them
could have thousands of instagram
followers yeah you guys have i don't
know i never said i didn't love you guys
i'm not i'm not gonna sugarcoat it
if someone famous steps in front of you
to give us a little swag a little
cheddar a little a little bit of that
guac we're gonna munch that up and then
we'll get back to your pathetic lives
afterwards okay
so leave us a note in the
can i call my mom to pick me up
she can't she's busy watching espn
wondering if the seahawks will acquire a
quarterback this year
you're so busy but someone in the chat
i'm sorry i just had to uh perry clemens
got the same name
last name are we siblings
that's what you're calling out save last
names uh same last names after he said
that horrible atrocious thing that you
guys didn't censor what did i say that
was atrocious about the seahawks oh well
this is this is all useless news but you
know what's not useless news the
headlines
oh my goodness hey michael jacquino gave
an interview to phase zero where he
discussed how much he is enjoying making
werewolf by night for disney plus he
reveals that they are right in the
middle of production and that he's quote
hopeful
end quote quite a quote wow uh and he
told me that so much there will be more
details and absolutely he's very quiet
the details will be shared i think it's
very interesting he's directing this
because he's a composer yeah
uh and i looked at his imdb he's
directed like a couple small things but
like they gave him this whole
project to do i wonder if he's just like
super into werewolves yeah
maybe he's just like the guy that
everybody knows is like super into
werewolves and he's just been like the
whole time he's just been like guys if i
ever get a chance to do horrible fun and
then finally one of his homies was like
all right dude let's give it to him for
his birthday he didn't do the harry
potter movie still number three he's
like i don't need to show that's when
they really
hey here's another headline eugene
cordero told screen rant that he will be
returning to loki season two as casey
uh cordero was one of the few seasoned
regulars that had not been previously
confirmed to return even though they
said like everyone's coming back yeah
but that's a weird thing to say because
there are hundreds of people involved
but yeah casey was the one who had the
drawer full of infinity stones do we
think he's like secret bigger role here
grabbing very small minuscule characters
and getting you very attracted to them
and i think that's just what he's going
to be reoccurring like if we did one
division again we'd get mustache guy
yeah we get mustache back in a second so
i think this is just our like um our
voice of reason well we know he's a we
know now that everyone who works at the
tva was like a variant pulled from their
lives like mind wiped or whatever right
so he maybe we'll learn more about who
he is i think the funny gag would just
be if he had like the same life
he works at an office
but like in that scenario there's like a
drawer full of like marbles that he
finds
like toodles and hook he lost his
marbles
you know i played doodles in a regional
production of uh peter pan when i was a
young woman oh yeah
i wonder
uh the best story from that a little
side story here for all of you mostly
for you three uh is the guy who played
uh hook in that production he when i was
a young teenager and he was like hey why
are you so fat and i was like wow that
was cool you're doing regional theater
hook wow
i did look a little chubby in my
tutorials
hey here's the headline deadliners
reporting good girls alum manny montana
is set as a series regular opposite
dominique thorne in marvel studios
disney plus series he's iron heart so
his role is yet unknown have you watched
uh good girls he's amazing i have not
watched good very nice i think he's
amazing uh also to say the least if you
guys have watched good girls he is very
quiet uh he's like he's a young man or
an older man he's like he's like a
gangster he like a money launderer okay
he's a money launderer and he's really
mean and so hot but like i think in iron
heart he'd be a good just like
uh cop like a good guy not a good cop
but like you know about no such thing
we'll get into that later all right um
yeah i don't know where uh he could be
on the show they're not really all we
know is going to be on the show right is
riri williams the character really
williams then i think shuri is going to
maybe on the show
[Music]
mechanic like for cars but like he's
like he's the mechanical one that just
like always has these pieces and he's
really mean about what if he works for
the dodc and starts looking into what's
going on true one talk i don't know one
talk i don't know hey we gotta interrupt
these headlines for a very important
segment that we have here on the break
room when the news breaks it's time for
the break room barbie watch
we don't care if you don't care about
the barbie film but we're so excited for
it and we cannot wait and now we have
our first image of ryan gosling as ken
throw it up on the screen this is not a
drill look at that look at that
but we're so excited i thought the the
the picture that came out of margot
robbie as barbie was just like oh it's
margot robbie in a car right but this is
like that's right
i can't wait for simula simulator sami
lose some of this i know that we
pronounced his name wrong constantly and
that is why he because he refuses the
super chat and until he does but he does
he does watch new rock stars because he
shared a video that me and mt did on oh
that's right that's right um but he and
issa rey's character who were i think
everyone's online or marine are the ones
dating or the barbie
couple and i'm like give me their photos
give me their photos he had to train to
do hip-hop dance for his role so i'm
like i want to know what his character
is about yes absolutely
needless confirmed say we will be at
barbie opening night oh yes as a family
we'll be doing a breakdown we'll be
doing our trailer reactions
theory videos yeah and always stay tuned
to uh the break room barbie uh
what is it what watch the bbw yeah
anytime we get late breaking barbie news
we will we will revamp the bbw i have to
buy song there will be no shortage of
bbw content on this channel moving
forward
uh hey here's the headline chris
hemsworth revealed that uh he had gotten
bored of his mcu character i think he
plays thor before he began working on
thor ragnarok with taika with tt this
was the quote he gave and some of you at
home might agree with this quote i
wasn't stoked with reading reading like
him
i can't do an australian accent you
can't isn't that it's inappropriate all
right let me get into it
i wasn't i wasn't stoked with what i've
done in thought too you know i was a
little disappointed in what i'd done i'm
getting a little cockney uh i didn't
think i drew the character in any way i
don't think i showed an audience
something unexpected and different by
order of the pinky blinders
it's such a shady thing to say for the
other three movies he did i know but it
is
yeah absolutely and i think in fairness
to
uh that that the the headline from the
source that we're getting that from was
a little misleading he's not saying like
the movie was bad right right he's
critiquing he was saying he was bored
with his before yeah he wasn't giving
him what he wanted he was born with his
performance or is he bored with where
thor was going i think i think
yeah but that's ultimately kind of falls
on him right like it's like he's got it
he's the one who's gonna show up o'shea
jackson for instance in kenobi they just
did not write that man that way right
but you know i think also he after thor
two right he does ghostbusters which
some of you may not enjoy but it really
showed people that he had the community
that's my role and i think because of
ghostbusters and men in black
international which nobody saw i saw it
uh that was like it kind of proved he
could handle the comedy and bringing in
tiger was a great move uh and we all
love worth now and lady ghostbusters was
the
cultural revolution of himbos
i mean there have obviously been himbos
in the past don't get me wrong but this
was like the modern revolution of him
yeah well the chatters certainly agree
with uh chris hemsworth his own analysis
of it they were also by a whopping
60 percent saying that they were bored
of thor before ragnarok yeah i mean it
was tough though when you go back and
watch store two there's a lot of stuff
in there they shut up that was very
important there's a lot of cool stuff in
there i remember watching it recently
and it's like i rewatched
one and i did not like it i rewatched it
and i was like oh this is too slow and
really boring not a kenneth brown a fan
i get it oh no it's also because you
know how time works with media sure it's
like oh i love this movie when it came
out because it was also the only movie
there yeah
i think it works both ways because i
think time does a lot to help uh captain
america the first avenger for sure
because that's part of the longer saga
that movie is more impactful than it was
just
i think i'm like this is we're going off
track
i think i like captain america's more
than thor's or iron man's okay uh which
it might be fighting words i don't know
that's fighting words
in america everywhere i can i rewatch
all of them and i was like i have more
fun watching captain america yeah but
now you know what you know i think at
the time iron man reigns supreme i like
trump more than captain america this
door was all over the place had
beautiful colors all the weird
shakespearean nature of it at the time
yeah the cap was my probably least
favorite of those three at the time
and to be fair i did not want to watch
captain america when it dropped the
first time i had to watch it like five
years later because i was like um i
really don't want to yeah i think no i
just i think one thing that we've
learned is that time
goes by so slowly
and time can do
so much
you know the righteous brothers are you
still mine
all right i gotta go uh here's a
headline in a new interview with
fandango psychology was asked about
whether or not thor love and thunder uh
could lead into a thor five uh and he
had quite an interesting response here's
a quote not gonna do the voice again uh
i haven't thought about it as part of a
new trilogy because every time i make a
film i think i'm never doing that again
because they're just too hard i would
never want to make a movie uh that was
my quote in the middle of his quote
he also said there's any film i've done
and he's done it eight times now eight
times i've said i think i'm just gonna
pack it in i had a good run and then
sure enough i get lured back in with a
yankee dollar i love the tournament
uh lured back in by them cookies and
they're lost like he didn't already win
an oscar the year he wasn't supposed to
win an oscar honestly should have went
to a little wait what could you
uh yeah they give you a gift basket full
of cookies it depends on which one
eternals did but the last one didn't
because i asked boss i was like did the
last one give you cookies and he was
like no they didn't give out cookies and
movies
yeah give us more tell us
more i'll let you guys know at thor love
and thunder if they give out cookies and
then also give you tessa thompson's
phone number
yeah that'd be great uh and more tycoon
news
gave an interview with total film where
he said he wants to create something new
and exciting with his star wars film
but i don't think that i'm any i'm in it
sorry i don't think that i'm any use in
the star wars universe making a film
where everyone's like ooh great well
that's the blueprints of the millennium
falcon and ah that's chewbacca's
grandmother that all stands alone that's
great though i would like to take
something new and create some new
characters and just expand the world
otherwise i feel like it's a very small
story i love this
make star wars movies about anything
else than anything we've already seen in
star wars chewbacca's grandmother
confirmed coming to
that could do that and get away with it
i think he's going to make it really fun
and approachable because i think star
wars fans are too nervous to get out of
the bubble
agree with you so much i think the
problem is we always say that oh we want
something new you want to make my friend
too far but then like andors trailer
comes out and it's like this is
basically
as close to just a tangent of the
existing star wars universes you can
have there's like two characters that
we've ever seen before and everybody's
like no
i thought there's not enough that i
recognize it and we can't have it this
way so what i'm saying is
pick a lane guys you want your stories
100 or you want to watch c-3po get
rubbed down with oil okay you get one of
the others you guys got mad when george
lucas gave the opportunity and now look
at where we're at uh a bunch of the same
tatooine shots
get off tattooing that's i'm begging you
please get off time
walker made for her son every time we
make another film and that god
sand planet i think the the only answer
is
we got a tattoo we in them oh god
oh that's a good one
i'm surprised no one's done that yet
yeah
uh chrissy said four five thousand would
have to be uh l d phil coulson that
somehow picked up mad wire from fina mad
not in the
ones that johnson chose someone did say
someone said michael shannon and i speak
oh yeah
i think they're holding they're waiting
they're waiting to put michael's [ __ ] i
mean christian bale was oh well i was
waiting for it again yeah i was waiting
for christian bailey too
a great villain is what bright girl said
uh which they might do but wasn't it
kind of implied that sylvia was like a
mix of enchantress and someone
else i don't know if it was implied but
i know that's what it was
off the internet in the comics kind of
right it was like enchantress but i
don't think they said i don't think that
was like kind of crossing them
i put her in i like it but you know
and a maybe just goes by a said danny
mcbride for thor five years yeah he
could be a good villain he could be a
good kenny powers they should put him in
if it's just kenny powers
getting powers of right
um
uh someone said will ferrell and i
disagree
oh wow i politely and respectfully
disagree adam sandler uncut gems
if i want to be stressed again to the
point
guys we're halfway to our breaking that
swear jar if you want to vote on who
gets to curse throw in some super chats
maybe he's throwing some super chats
about what you thought about the most
recent episode of obi-wan kenobi i'm
about to get into it with our discussion
but i also want to shout out uh aspen
silver that said thor versus las vegas
temptation
and i love that what if it's just him
constantly on a slot machine
last spin come on he's
i can quit anytime let's go back to the
mask
claw machine or whatever okay you guys
let's talk about kenobi
we're on episode five and i think this
is spoilers ahead right yeah we're gonna
tell you spoilers
spoilers um episode five of kenobi just
dropped and i thought i could love the
third sister more than i do but this
episode made me love her more i don't
care what anyone says especially my mom
if you're watching because she called me
and said
i don't care about her
i love third sister so next week is our
last is the finale so make sure you drop
your questions for the finale you might
have or questions you have about this
episode that dropped tonight uh last
night and we will make sure to answer
them by the end but anyways uh and then
we also have our star wars expert here
tommy mister tommy mr bechtol yeah he's
on wikileaks if you haven't watched
wikileaks already
so he'll answer
and wiki feet
oh okay ooh i love this uh oh wait horny
police
will we see luke use the force in the
finale you guys
this question i want do you guys not
think we'll see i don't think do we not
want to see it or do we think we can see
it i don't think luke will see anything
that's going on i i don't know hmm
i think they're not going to get
something that baby face that they're
gonna oh do you think i think she's
gonna race yeah it's gonna be like on
the outskirts
i think maybe lars might show up and be
like coming in here you know what i mean
yeah uh put up the fisticuff maybe aunt
peru gets a little she pulls out the
blue milk bottle and bashes it over
someone's hand
who i mean kind of my dark horse sport
like person to show up would be a
younger cobb van
vance who's like also looking for luke
for a different reason he'd be like 20
but maybe he's like just a young justice
like a hot 20 year old cobb yeah like
he's like he's like a
free freedom town what was that place
called moss something
something like that
oh i can't remember that was it
uh i see a lot of people in the chat
yeah no you're good that i'm saying
please god no i hope he doesn't
well we were kind of talking about this
around the office right like luke is
unaware of the force he doesn't know it
but the show is kind of the people have
been thinking that oh leia was using the
force when riva was trying to enter her
mind right she was kind of resisting
with the little force but she doesn't
it's the idea of you have the force but
you don't know it yeah yeah cause luke
was bragging about shooting womp rants
yeah to bigs and like
he just made it seem like oh it's easy i
can shoot well and it's like maybe
you're using the force and you don't
know it
could
so could i i guess i don't know the star
wars timeline as best as you two so
please correct me okay
oh my god
so
can when when
when can vader i guess see luke using
the force could he have seen it now is
that just something that was never
explored before the question uh
are you asking me
he's aware of you yeah yeah he's aware
of what you can of course there's a
there's a comic when uh marvel
comics was making the draft theater
comics cause disneyland anyways uh post
the events of a new hope
uh uh darth vader hires
boba fett to figure out who this hot
shot pilot was who made this shot
because he was fine he was like i feel
something right but he's fine we saw
that in a new hope so he asked um uh
boba fett to forget who it is what
figures it out and comes and tells him
and he's like his name's skywalker and
okay uh uh darth vader's like
and he
he like okay he's standing in front of a
window on on the star destroyer and he
breaks it it cracks but he doesn't want
to show uh boba fett he knows what's up
so he's like in the whole window cracked
sorry he holds that very far too yeah
yeah he's like
flooded in the suit and boba fett just
kind of like that was weird i'm gonna
get out of here
from what we understand that's when he
finds out who luke's guy what that that
pilot was luke skywalker and then he's
like i have a boy oh so the chad said
well we see luke use the force uh 59
said no and 40 percent said it's closer
than i thought it was gonna be that i
thought it was gonna be a blowout i
i i really wanna see luke use the force
no i'm gonna say he's not gonna because
he's dumber than leia oh i like that
figured it out he's probably a couple
years behind
that's a great point however i do think
that we might see something similar to
like
you know the famous men in black 2 movie
where rosario dawson's character was
like things always happened that she
didn't realize and she thought she was
unlucky but really it was because she
was influencing them without knowing
like luke is probably like that lucky
like lucky in like
in his adventures his whole life in his
life
yeah like little things have always kind
of turned his way we might discover
something like that that would be like
the phrase i accidentally interrupted
you i'm so sorry when i was
was i gonna say something yeah you were
you say something amazing right now will
vader end up on tatooine to search for
luke sorry i feel like well we know he
hates he's racing right i think he's
gonna be okay so this is he's he going
there yeah well yeah right yeah why
would he be going there isn't he okay so
i think okay so when this is what i was
thinking they're chasing the [ __ ]
they're chasing the ship that's going
there
but do you not think what did we not
think about that or what do we think
about that scene where uh obi-wan kenobi
is straight up like
something's off something's wrong do you
think i don't think that was about the
third sister i think that had something
to do with anakin oh okay i took it to
be that he realized that the third that
luke was in danger
but i don't know why he would sense that
i don't know i thought it was something
i i thought it was going to be with
darth vader so i was like oh darth vader
got a hold of something he's got he
knows where they're going um oh sorry
you guys we reached over a hundred
dollars in the swear jar oh
i guess this also this question does go
into our third question of will riva get
to luke before obi won because like
what's her new plan
she has no ship she's just well she's
damned
not dead no one ever dies no one ever
dies uh
maybe she's gonna go to thundercat get
her guts fixed first and then go after
after uh
luke i don't know that seems like a good
idea but she has to crawl her way
because also the bale's message just
said tatooine yeah it didn't say like
right here on tatooine it just said
and
maybe just ask around i don't know i
want to see uncle owen like lay down the
law that's what i'm hoping to say i want
to see on glow and fight yeah yeah get
in a fight just be like who are you
looking for yeah we ain't got no little
boys here
only
do we are we happy where riva's at right
now were we content with what happened
with her i wish she would have struck
struck at a different moment yeah she
really missed her moment she should have
teamed up with canopy i don't know why
he was implying like let's work together
on this one and she's like i don't want
to work with anybody i don't trust
anyone anymore yeah um
oh wow do i have to do it right now or
can i like save it i think they want to
hear it they want to hear it right now
just pick someone's name out and swear
at the moment
we got some super
[ __ ]
wonderful stuff yeah thank you film
juice i'm outdoors you're nice
and the chats that swear to me
i love a good swear to me but well [ __ ]
all y'all you're all [ __ ] great i
just want to say i really loved when uh
the grand inquisitor og showed up again
and was so sassy about it he was like
hello
you're done screwed up oh i'm still here
look at that little prank we played on
you where we gave you the pin and then
we take it away any of us surprised no
were any of us surprised when he showed
up
one of the super chatters asked how
could how did the grand inquisitor
survive with no back to tank and i think
maybe they were i don't know if they
were talking about the new grand
inquisitor riva or the original but we
talked about on the show i think
yesterday that the the grand inquisitors
have two stumps
or whatever
oh okay so that's why that's why you
survived you got stabbed in one of those
this is how riva survives is that once
you become grand inquisitor no matter
who you are you get a second step yeah
you got that she's going to survive
because i also you have two stomachs and
you get stabbed to the lightsaber i
think you can still just die yeah i
don't think the number of stomachs no it
matters it's not hearts in the zelda
game matter i really want i'm riding
this train that now you brought into my
mind about her going to thundercat and
being rebuilt because we didn't i like
that the one woman was rebuilt in the
middle and i want to see if we see riva
again which i want to see why i want her
to be half robot in the center um
thundercat the new uh is he the benedict
one of the star wars universe where he
gets to be in every star wars project
they're poor pow ons
you want to hear our
uh thundercat gets his tattoos at the
same place i get my tattoos by the same
time two artists do they switch their
nails or is they the same needle
i said same blood i'll pay more for the
same thing i'll play yeah i'll be moving
the same needle we get
we both get anime tattoos at the same
anime shop in l.a and we will cross
paths when we have a schedule at the
same time because our tattoo
appointments take both five hours
and so we always have to he's always
like i'll bump for her and i'm like
maybe we can just meet up at the same
time and hang out because i have a lot
of questions matching tattoos let's get
matching touching the thundercats
and he's very excited to be in star wars
he talks about it all the time and he
hopes that they bring away who wouldn't
be excited to be in star wars
and he watches new rock stars so
directly
i'm jessica the person that keeps taking
your time for tattoos yeah now you know
where to find her yeah oh oh wait no
don't do it don't do that but you guys
let us know about any uh questions you
have in the chat about what you think
the finale's gonna look like yeah uh
what you have about the last night
episode that we didn't touch on because
you know i like to talk about third
sister the most but there's a lot of
characters we missed like o'shea jackson
kumail's character coming back and now
swindling poor people
dropping their message on the ground
there's a lot of things that we could be
talking about more so let us know in the
chat we have more questions we'll get
them at the end fire them in the chat
give us everything you got speaking of
giving everything you got
we want to thank our friends at helix
i guess yeah thank you helix i myself as
you know i'm the owner of a helix
mattress and it allows me to sleep
soundly so soundly in fact that uh my
idiot roommates no matter how loud
they're being cannot wake me up i have
sold you before on this show i have loud
inconsiderate roommates my helix
mattress is my best chance at a
comfortable night's sleep
joey i want to plead to you now
personally house pets uh flies are not
house pets or subjects for your
experiments there's no need to collect
them uh simply shoot them outside or
close the windows it's weird and it's
creepy and i want you to stop also last
night you left the dvd menu for the
matrix on at a high volume for the
entire night and if anyone who's watched
dvds recently has seen the menu for the
matrix it's very loud it's very intense
quick repeat
yeah it's got a quick recoil if you know
what i'm saying
anyway helix sleep has a quiz that takes
just two minutes to complete and matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you and who
wouldn't want the perfect mattress
anyone wake up setting out to find a bad
mattress not me no take a two-minute
quiz even if you're someone like me who
hates testing tested well below grade
level his entire time he was in school
public school this quiz is easy you
can't fail it with helix you're getting
a mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you sleep okay
everybody's unique that's not true i've
known a few people that are shockingly
similar
there's a lot of boring people out there
there's a lot of boring people in one
world and they don't deserve good
mattresses yeah okay everybody deserves
that great let me put this away if
you've got it if you've got a
garbage personality
you don't deserve a good mattress
but if you're bringing that thunder to
the conversation if you're dynamic
you're unique and helix knows that so
they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have super
soft medium and firm mattresses i like a
mattress that's like an old steely
british woman you lay down on her and
she says no today love
pops you right out of bed
you sleep hot they have cooling
mattresses that are good for you
mattress is great for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains and
they even have a helix plus mattress for
you plus size sleepers out there again
helix
hit me on camera four
[Applause]
this morning when i woke up
i was i heard a faint sound i thought it
was my roommate you know trying to turn
off his tv but instead it was my
mattress going
[Laughter]
[Music]
help me
[Applause]
now this matrix
has served its country
nobly okay it's a helix mattress it's
comfortable as hell i love it however
helix if you're listening to me give me
that big body boy mattress okay i'm a
big big beefy boy and i need a mattress
it's not going to scream out in pain
when i sleep on them
matt gertie and then chad said maybe i
have a trash personality because i have
a bad mantra oh maybe
yeah that's right you have trash
personality most of them do okay
hey in the poll uh thoughts and put a
super pull up right now who's not a
trash person
do you have a trash personality yes or
no all right we gotta bring this home
okay just go to helixsleep.com
slash break room take their two minute
quiz i bet you can do it in a minute 45
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that'll give you the best sleep
of your life right now helix is offering
up to 200 off all mattresses orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
slash break room that's 200 off up two
and two free pillows like i said one for
your head and one for your lead okay you
can use them on each one
helixsleep.com
break room you use your pillows however
you want i like to put them over my head
like a cartoon that's listening to loud
music oh i like that prank
uh and after you're done checking out
helix be sure to go to
newrockstarsmerch.com check out all of
our awesome merch options we've got a
limited edition latest obsession shirt
right now based on this marvin called
cosmic daydream beautiful shirt
beautiful design beautiful people wear
it uh you could be a beautiful person
too you probably already are check it
out newrockstarsmerch.com if you buy
that latest obsession you unlock the
opportunity to get a shout out which
will appear on our inside marvel show
uh our our miss marvel after show and if
enough people in the chat say yes to the
poll we'll make merch that says we're
trash people yeah yeah
but if you say you're a trash person
doesn't that show a level of
self-awareness yeah it's okay to be
aware that you're attracted but that
means you're not a trash person
what kind of science bull nanny are you
trying to spit out you're a dumpster
dude or a badass bin betty it doesn't
matter to me
you're all welcome we're gonna get trash
people had bands made for me and jess in
our headband line it's coming
oh i'm talking to phillip about it don't
worry we're gonna gucci to moochie
headband we're getting everything coming
out soon don't worry
speaking of not worrying i know we're
getting a little late in the show people
are probably getting nervous that we
weren't gonna have mandatory fun we are
it's time for mandatory fun
thank goodness
that's not enough that's not enough
people with trash personnel i told you
the majority majority would be trash i'm
not wrong i'm never wrong about this
guys takes one to no one now
mandatory fun is the segment that has
captured the nation in its steely grip
it's the segment so nice we play the
graphic twice hit it again oh my gosh
too many
too
the segment so nice we don't hit it
again we play the picture of ryan
gosling as ken hit the picture of ryan
gosling
[Applause]
yeah barbie breakdown i know what he's
capable of back there let me push him to
his limits break room barbie watch
that's right now we've got mandatory fun
where i make my three best friends have
a little bit of non-optional joy with me
unfortunately you guys
no i can't be here for it no you're
already doing this i've got to die
unfortunately i am getting mongoose
platelets transfused
into my into my bones human platelets
i'm sorry i'm getting mongoose platelets
but i did find
a really great substitute for this what
if i give you my platelet i need
mongoose platelets
don't worry well tommy can't be here for
mandatory fun i guess i don't know so
someone said i'm gonna fire tommy if he
leaves again
t.d jones thank you very super chat it
is time for mandatory fun you caprice
say an f for joey that uh tommy's
roommate please get a helix mattress
it's amazing uh and you know what it is
time for mandatory fun play the graphic
john love you john john they love you
the super chat's lovely oh that's just
for you you could uh pretend not you can
you can
create that
i said it wrong i apologize uh and ammo
is sending a super chat saying vader
will go to tattooing for bank i'm back
now oh my gosh i'm the host is it kylo
ren it is eyes
clearly dead in the movie character kylo
ren oh he dies i hate that i can see
your neck and skins
what do you mean still
i am a different person
i am kylo ren the last few years haven't
gone so good for me oh okay that's okay
i've put on a lot of stress weight no i
don't think that's the problem today
i'm wearing a children's version of my
pants
they don't make these masks for
grown-ups
my name is yeah my name is t thomas
michael beck glow
oh hello
[Laughter]
last night's episode of kenobi
showed us a character we had seen
breaking the sacred rule of film and
television clearly dead stabbed to death
motionless not breathing
returning to life
as the grand inquisitor
joined us again on-screen
[Laughter]
quiet you have to forget the past
kill it if you have to
now
the grand inquisitor despite being
stabbed in one of his poo hard stomachs
[Music]
has come back to life
in search of a wife okay
that got me thinking
why can't i come back
yes i turned into ben solo and then
kissed my girlfriend of one minute
and then disappeared
but that doesn't mean i'm gone for good
right huh right right right jj right
ryan right taika
maybe tyler come back eat your movie
someone in the chat said that's kyle
redd
i'm kylo ren that you order on wish
wish granted and it's a curse
anyway
i thought it would be a lot of fun today
if everybody came up with a character
who had very clearly died in a movie or
tv show okay and justified them coming
back to life i'm talking heads getting
cut off
i'm talking balls getting blown off
death by ball blood letting
i'm talking pregnancy death
difficult breach birth
oh my god i got a house on the prairie
[ __ ] oh my god
our cameraman could not hold it
i've i've got one all right
tommy
beckglow what's your name tommy beckham
tommy kyle i'm coming i've got one uh so
we all remember the first jurassic park
film yes i know and uh uh the first
gentleman we see dies eaten by he's
sucked into our raptor cage
uh no we're getting to that guy we're
kidding the first guy gets sucked in
he's like shoot uh
shoot
it's the call open for the film uh then
eventually we meet the block chucking
lawyer yeah uh who gets famously eaten
on the john yeah uh
but did you know
we see the t-rex like
get them
like chew him up so on the whole he
swallows him home
my life
he slides through the stomach and gets
pooped out by the t-rex
and he's still alive that's how i think
they bring him back that's the only way
i'd ever hire an attorney if it came out
someone's ass
not just anyone's ass a dinosaur a
dinosaur's ass yeah so what you're
saying is that t-rex had a great ass
and that lawyer's head was all the way
up it oh yes love a good heat reference
thank you tyler
it's tommy beckham
hello all right anyone else
anyone else want to play my wicked games
illegal is it me oh goodness
okay
i would like to see
the taunton from empire street oh okay
oh come on i got split open i want to
see that guy come back because
that tantan had also been appointed
grand inquisitors oh okay
through an extra little tummy okay
weird worms yeah it only sliced open hot
only sliced open the the one
tummy and hit luke inside every time
he's still going i actually think that's
brilliant because now that content can
rent himself out as an airbnb as well
it's true he's an adult he can't yes
yeah yeah and he'll have like really
weird rules like quiet hours begin at
eight that's right free wi-fi
continental breakfast served once i eat
[ __ ] on my throat
i love the idea that the todd tons have
their own uh system of government that
involves a good yeah what do you want
pancakes i'm going to eat a short stack
and [ __ ]
into your mouth
don't just don't touch my cape
don't touch my helmet
do you have a death rebirth i do as long
as tommy doesn't look at me okay
stop it where are you tommy because i
can sense you
i'm right in front it's right because
our elbows are touching tommy kylo
i'm gonna you know uh one of the most
unjustified deaths in tv history
glenn from the walking dead
and i'll never be over it like a lot of
the internet and i'll be honest i
stopped watching the show after that
because i'm very sensitive and it takes
a lot to about the first fake out death
you were like that one i don't care
but no because glenn didn't deserve to
die and so i want them to bring glenn
back and be like i was a joke or
something i don't know maybe maybe he
turns into a good zombie
they bring him back but he's got severe
brain damage
so he's like i'm back
and they're like uh glenn we're not cool
with this he's like tomatoes and they're
like glenn i think you need to see a
doctor i'll be honest i i shouldn't be
writing for the walking dead because my
emotions get ahead of me all the time
absolutely absolutely i think um i'm
just a woman i did see someone in the
chat had the idea of you know you have
john travolta's character vincent from
pulp fiction yeah that was stuck in like
a groundhog day oh yeah does that mean
he just keeps coming back and getting
shot over and over again he like ducks
one time uh gets out of the way when he
finally cracks the loop we get to see
what was in the goddamn briefcase
remember show me what's in the book i
don't want to know unfortunately
unfortunately you're all wrong oh yeah
no the correct answer
is macaulay culkin's character thomas
from my girl oh he jumps into that pond
covered in bee sticks
only to emerge like slop thing more
powerful than before
shooting his vines out at that little
girl and her father dad acroid who wants
a morgue
and then drags them back in then he
drags them to hell oh okay they never
make it to california they never make it
to california for my girl too which
features a scene at the la brea target
monster goes on down to whatever town
bridge to terabithia takes place in and
he saves the little girl before she
i'm just saying she knew she shouldn't
be walking across that rickety bridge in
the rain and storm once it's raining man
how dare her dad give the dog back to
the boy and that they should you guys
i'm gonna we could talk to her all day
and it's not his fault that she went in
the rain to go back to the place well
that wraps up talking
a weekly bridge to terabithium rant
session
your revival of glenn they want him to
come back uh but you were very close
with uh whitney's tauntaun theory yeah
uh
and uh you caprica throwing in another
super giant hey john stop this madness
i'm effing dying hashtag vote for tommy
uh they want to vote for tommy
can you get tommy back from the doctor
uh let me see if he's done with his okay
we did have a couple other questions in
the chat about what they thought about
speed answer the ones that's the answer
and we've crossed the swear jar again
thanks to everyone who's been sending
his super chats so why don't we throw in
some of our answers to these questions
with some curse words
thank you you could uh
uh
someone says cal saves luke thoughts
devon salas says cal saves young luke
thoughts you guys have thought
funny
when i go to get mongoose platelets i'm
the villain
but you guys get platelets and you're
the hero that doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense oh
i think it would be [ __ ] crazy if cal
shows up on on petuni
to save to save uh a young luke i also
think luke would remember that moment
and talk about it this year yeah oh gee
willie p says vader hates sand and
tuscan raiders to further his training
tatooine would be the perfect place to
become the mask
big preston said did anyone notice
obi-wan doing those phantom kicks in the
air when he was using his lightsaber
i did not i did but he was fighting yes
when he's fighting anakin and like the
flashback he can't doing some kicks
madness uh up funk setlist love the name
i honestly will steal it will riva turn
to the light again i okay you can right
i i mean i think darth vader proved you
can commit genocide across the galaxy
and at the very beginning to be like
yeah i'm sorry i'm kidding i love you
and then you get to be a force ghost
jedi are the problem jedi are the
problems you can do anything for your
children
you can do anything okay for your
children
and then return to the law
wade wilson famous uh deadpool said if
vader farts can it leave the suit
i think that's like part of it it would
probably get exhaled out right yeah no i
wanted to get started i wanted to get
stuck that's a big question punishment
for killing his wife also that's a big
question that is
he's a guy that likes the smell of parts
um you know you know if you if you have
to fart and you don't let it out you
like hold it in and it just kind of goes
away right it gets reabsorbed back into
your body and you probably like burp it
out
we all know people whose bodies are
farts right we all know a few people
that are born literally the german man
in uh hellboy golden army he was also
referred to as just a human fart
uh the new rockstars chat says we need
to wrap this up please oh man your
rockstars chad's got places to go dying
folks uh we love chatting with you today
is that john we're so glad and joe
probably yeah
uh we we gotta go john really wants to
be finished we like talking to you guys
but johnny yeah yeah john wasn't such a
big bastard you guys go to john costa on
twitter
let's throw bomb emojis in the chat for
john because we don't like him but we
love all of your roomies thanks for
being here today we'll be back tomorrow
to talk ms marvel so get all your miss
marvel questions ready uh thank you so
much for joining us join us every day on
the break room we'll see you tomorrow
have a great rest of your wednesday
latest getters bye
[Music]